the advent of mixed reality means that
the constraints we've come to expect
from a screen based life disappear
imagine the world has your desktop and
with this footage shot exclusively for
wire through magically technology you
can see some immediate obvious
applications of mixed reality to your
everyday life from your calendar to your
weather report to your emails even
keeping tabs on projects the world can
be your desktop conquered the new
zealand edmund hillary a got his first
mail and congratulatory telegrams from
george lo the fellow come to man and
expedition colleague us 35 miles from
Kathmandu capital in Nepal Hillary and
Tenzing were welcome that when detonated
by their fellow members of the
expedition
[Music]